hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
as you watch this I should be on holiday
in the Lake District I'm going tomorrow
so that's great news of course for me
but it does mean I haven't had quite the
usual time to create a video with all
the usual editing and high production
values etc so I thought instead I'd do
something quicker I'd make a quick vlog
style video on how to work online and
how to create your dream job online
because I do believe I've got a
blueprint that anyone can use in order
to well be pretty much any type of work
they want to on the web so I've been
working online for the last eight years
successfully I haven't had to get a
proper job and during that time I've had
tons of good experiences that I've been
incredibly grateful for I've got to
create a top-selling app I've got to
work with people around the world and
travel to meet them I've got to have a
book published up and published in
magazines I've got to play with cool
technology before it's been released to
the public all this stuff and none of it
would have been possible if I didn't
work online if I'd been told when I was
a kid that this would be my job when I
was a grown-up then I probably thought
you were pulling my leg so I've
obviously still got an awful lot to
learn I'm not rich by any means but I
find my work very fulfilling I think
it's on a great trajectory and I don't
think that's coincidence I've got some
big plans for my career and for the
bonilla in particular and hopefully I
think if I continue to follow this
blueprint then I'll be able to see them
through so the strategy that I'm gonna
talk to you about is something called
spring boarding I came up with that term
as far as I'm aware if probably is
talked about
elsewhere under a different name but I'm
not aware of what it is and basically
the central premise is you're going to
build up experiences and contacts and
successes and use each one to help build
momentum and launch yourself towards
that next successful project
so when I started working online I
finished University I moved in with my
mum and like probably most of you I
didn't have the funds or the experience
or the contacts that would be necessary
to launch some kind of big ambitious
entrepreneurial project so instead I use
something called bootstrapping so
bootstrapping this isn't the time I made
up bootstrapping means that you do some
kind of work as a side project it well
as your main project in order to bring
yourself some kind of income that you
can then use in order to give yourself
the flexibility and the finances that
you can then invest into
your bigger dream projects will start
off as the side projects so in my case
is an example I started off as a writer
this is a very simple business model all
that to do was do the writing was asked
to do send it and then get paid by a
paypal it was stable reliable and it
gave me flexibility in time so that I
could develop my own skills as a
programmer as an editor as a
videographer so I could learn about
fitness and etc and all of this meant I
was able to pursue the things I really
was interested in at the same time
though bootstrapping this way also gave
me experience and it gave me contacts it
meant that I got used to writing large
volumes and focusing it meant I learned
how you know working online works I got
to use all the tools I made contacts
with other bloggers blog owners I
learned about marketing I learned about
how to create a blog and all of this
improve to be incredibly useful
so that's bootstrapping and if you're
starting out I highly recommend it then
at the same time I recommend building a
personal brand and viewing yourself as a
personal brand what I mean by this is
that each job you do and each contact
you make you're going to add to your
portfolio and that portfolio you can
then display on a website on LinkedIn
you can talk about it with people when
you're networking and basically you're
trying to build yourself up into this
kind of superstar in the industry that
you want to be in so it's not enough to
just take the work and then quietly
beaver away on it you want to maybe vlog
about it or blog about it you want to
talk about it on LinkedIn you want to
post it wherever you can and then this
way you'll find that each success was
tracked new successes towards you so as
most of you know I also work for
anti-authority that opportunity came
about partly because I had a YouTube
channel ready for the new I likes
talking on video and it's partly because
I've made apps for cold fusion cold
fusion was interested in working with me
probably because I'd already made multi
speed multitasking so you see each
success leads to the next success then I
got a book published on app development
which was probably partly because I've
been working with Android Authority and
had those previous successes and then by
putting all this onto my CV on LinkedIn
and posting about it on videos like this
and on my blog I can then attract more
better quality work to myself having
built up that expertise that experience
and having proven myself
built some Authority so in that regard
I'm treating myself as a brand not just
as an employee or a service provider and
this is something I think can benefit
anyone even if you are traditionally
employed in a nine-to-five job create
yourself that blog think about the
experiences you've got and think about
how you can work on that experiences and
gain more whether that means doing an
online course or that means that night
classes whether it just means
volunteering to work one day a week I
worked at writers news magazine and was
an editor and writer there for a year
and I wasn't read and paid for that so
but it's really helped me in terms of my
career it probably helped me to land
some of those jobs as a freelance writer
so you see each thing you do new job you
take on should in some way be progress
in your career and helping you build
towards your eventual goals and giving
you the power so that you can start
choosing which work you want to take on
and choosing how much you want to charge
for it as well of course I like to think
of this as personal R&D so R&D being
research and development so if you go to
a company like Google or Microsoft they
have an R&D department they'll invest
money there and then this department
will work on projects they'll try out
new technologies they'll do research and
then that allows them to potentially
release new exciting products that
otherwise wouldn't have been possible of
course some of them will amount to
nothing it's the same thing with
yourself you can't just be working in
your business you know doing the work
that you have to do to survive you need
to make time to work on your business to
improve the way you're branding yourself
to improve your skillset to improve the
way you're presenting yourself so it's
only self employed that means giving
yourself some time to learn programming
editing design whatever it is that will
help you to progress your career and if
you're regularly employed it might just
mean like I say doing some kind of
course or it might mean you know
volunteering or just putting in some
extra hours or just updating your CV
with all this stuff so that you're more
and more appealing for those future
projects but then that's really where
the springboarding comes in and where
you start building towards your bigger
goals because I think you should start
out with all this with some kind of
vision of what you eventually want to
achieve and what you eventually want to
be like I say I've got big plans for the
bi-linear we're talking like evil genius
style plans except for not evil and
probably not genius either basically
have some kind of grand vision a vision
is diffent from a goal and then have the
smaller steps that you need to take in
order
get there and my favorite example of
this because sometimes you can make this
progress not linear but rather kind of
tangential so doing you might work in a
different industry that still helps you
work towards your goal on my favorite
example of this is Sylvester Stallone
who wanted to be a big actor obviously
is now but he didn't get there through
the usual channels didn't get there by
taking on bit roles and gradually you
know acting and pick of the bigger
movies what he did instead was he wrote
an amazing script that being rocky and
then he used that as a leverage in order
to land himself for leading role the
studio's liked it so much that they were
willing to take that risk on him because
they wanted that script so he didn't
have the excessive did he wanted the
traditional way to went a different
route instead likewise my plans are of
course to use the Pioneer as a kind of
platform it attracts other work to me
you know it demonstrates what I can do
at the same time it means that if I
launch something like an app or like a
book then I can talk to you guys about
it and if you like it then hopefully you
might check it out say I wanted to do a
Kickstarter to create an app that would
help your fitness and brain training
which maybe I do by the way then I think
they're having this as a platform and
maybe under the authority as well if
they were you know willing then I could
reach a bigger audience and at the same
time having that experience to someone
who's written books on development as
someone who's made a big app I'd have a
much greater chance of winning the trust
of people to back that project and make
it a reality
likewise having the contact with other
sites means that I can get them to cover
my story you know so each success is
building towards the next and you have
to have that end goal in mind be also
have to put in the grind do the horrible
work and sometimes each day in order to
get there and that's how you use
springboarding to accomplish pretty much
any kind of job you want the key
distinction to make here's the
difference between a dream of vision and
a goal so if you've got a dream or a
vision that's basically like it's more
abstract it's what you picked yourself
as in the future whether that means
you're just highly successful in your
field and influential that means you're
a good family man or woman whether it
means that you're in incredible shape
that's the vision is not it's not
concrete you haven't decided I want to
be this weight or I want to earn this
much money then you've set the goals and
the most successful goals are ones that
are small steps
you can do every single day and you can
even break this down into large goals
and smaller goals so for me a goal that
I've got is to publish three books I'm
on my second one and each book I'm gonna
hopefully move more more towards broader
topics which will then hopefully give me
more credibility when I want to cover
other subjects in future and maybe move
towards a larger publisher because then
that can help me to promote my blog much
as Tim Ferriss this blog was highly
successful after the 4-hour workweek but
then you've got the even smaller goals
you have to do every single day but
that's what you want to concentrate on
so for me that was writing 10,000 words
a day every single day in order to keep
those clients happy and view it might be
something completely different if you're
working out of course it means not
thinking about the shape you want to be
at the end of the day but instead just
thinking about doing a workout four
times a week those are the goals you
focus on in the short term because
they're complete within your control
they're things that you can pass or fail
at rather than being abstract distant
things but it's the abstract distant
things that gives you the trajectory and
that gives you the motivation and the
inspiration to keep going and keep in
mind that as you gain more experience as
you learn what it's like to work in our
industry your eventual vision and your
trajectory you might change in fact it
probably will and that's a good thing as
you learn more what you like doing what
you're good at what your skills are and
that's how you start to learn your kind
of life purpose and it does sound a bit
hammy a bit cheesy but there does come a
point where you start to realize what
you have to offer and what you want to
do with your life and it becomes a lot
more clear but don't worry if it's not
like that
right away you don't need the perfect
plan right away you just need to have a
rough vision of where you want to be
that's going to motivate you to get up
fed every day and do the work and then
you need to break it down it's the
smallest steps that you can do every
single day as long as they're moving you
slowly in the right direction and then
you can plan out your route that you see
different opportunities to work with
people to bulk up your portfolio as they
come along and have that end goal in
mind have that vision that's what Arnie
would always do but at the same time be
willing to put in the grind daily work
because it doesn't come overnight and
that's the difference between
springboarding and working your way up
and developing the skills and the
knowledge and the experience in the
contacts and the portfolio versus just
saying I want to be this quitting your
day job and then investing all your
money into doing it like I say the web
makes this more possible than ever
before so
whatever your dream is whatever your
goal is start taking on smaller work
start taking on different opportunities
that learn the skills you need and blog
about it log about it create a social
media account because then we put
yourself out there the more you take
those opportunities the more you'll find
they present themselves and eventually
you can hopefully achieve whatever kind
of dream career you want so you found
this video useful interesting guys and
it's a bit different than usual I do
like to do ones on working online and
online business every now and then and
I'm very happy to answer your questions
so if you have any then please leave
them in the comments down below and I'll
do my best and yeah I'll be back to
regular schedule when I return from my
holiday and I'll be doing that video on
the home batcaves I'm gonna be covering
a samurai training ninja training I'll
be talking more about the tropics I've
got the flow stack video on the way
still so if that all sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching thanks so much
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now